This is obviously very important this question
Gwendoline
if there were one character (Hodor)
That you wish hadn't been killed (Hodor)
Who would it be? (Hodor)
Well, I mean this to people obviously
one
is someone who was a
Magnificent presence in the series who happens to be hosting this panel?
and also Catelyn stark
fake answer real answer
Alfie
Who would I like to be brought back to life?
Yeah pretty much
um?
I would say
Kahl drogo, I like Kahl Drogo
Khal Drogo
definitely, Khal Drogo
Conleth?
Catelyn
And you
oh you have to say that don't say that
okay, not you
Catelyn and, no, you
Um I'm still hurting about Ned
Still breaks my heart
takes a while to get over that one.
I also have a flame for Barristan Selmy
Hold one up for Barristan
Sophie?
I just really loved working with Jack Gleeson so much that I have to say Joffrey
He was so fun to hate
Wow, he was such a good husband.
Very generous man
Yeah, I have no choice. I have to say my baby girl Serene
That still hurts, big time
I think I am still heartbroken about Hodor, like I still
Can't quite fit into it, but I you know I just love your guys like whole thing
So I think my answer is Hodor
Like genuinely
Yeah, two answers again first and foremost the legitimate answer is Robb stark
And the second answer is if there's one character that I wish they hadn't killed
It'd be Jon Snow just to save us having to talk about it every five minutes for a year
Whole year was pretty bad
That was a pretty crummy year
Yeah, you know I have to go out in the newspapers about that, someone asked me for like 37th time that hour
Is Jon Snow coming back, and I just lost it. I was like you know what? I don't care
And the next day in the paper. It said Kristian Nairn hates Kit Harrington
I didn't say that
Isaac yeah you be very careful
Jay
Yeah actually, some of the diar wolves
I'd bring back Hodor.
You didn't even like the diar wolf